okay so my favorite line of all time in
the history of Cinema is
goes like this
I'm just a girl
standing in front of a boy
asking him to love her
it's from Notting Hill and I love that
movie
I brought this
for you from home so I thought I'd give
it to you
thank you
I don't know it's just I mean that's
such a romantic movie and that's that's
the moment when the two characters that
you want to end up together just are
completely vulnerable with one another
and and yet in that vulnerability
there's the sense of you know just you
no one can predict which way it's gonna
go
my husband is laughing at me right now
why are you laughing
I'm serious about it I love that moment